[Musique]
nous vous accueillons pour célébrer le
solstice d'hiver ou Yalda Yala qui est
qui signifie
la victoire de la lumière
sur
l'obscurité
cette année
est différent c'est ça ne ressemble pas
à aucun il y a d'autres nous avons vécu
cette année il y a la couleur de
révolution à notre regard ça veut dire
que c'est plus rouge que j'avais les
femmes et les hommes
afghan soutient les revolutions
iraniennes le peuple iranien puisque
nous sommes frère et sœur depuis la nuit
des temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis d'origine iranienne et on
célèbre la nuit de tous les ans et du
coup c'était important pour moi de la
célébrer en étant tout en étant en
cohérence avec ce qui se passe en Iran
en ce moment la répression est tellement
forte que c'est difficile pour les
afpants de lutter mais nous il faut
qu'on les garde en tête dans notre culte
aussi pour l'Iran et et on espère
vraiment que le changement en Iran va
aussi influer sur l'Afghanistan et va
aussi provoquer un changement
l'Afghanistan de même ordre
[Musique]